one of the great things about you know
doing all of this work in maths is that
now now that we have like information
and we have taken this whole process and
boiled it down to a formula it brings it
down to something that she's so
effortlessly simple to calculate even
though it's actually kind of missing
geometrically okay so you begin by
quoting the formula right bigger x1 plus
B Y 1 plus C although Bo okay some
variations on this thing make it just
slightly tricky is that mice they might
give you the point in terms of some
geometric features and then just keep it
coordinates or alternatively they might
not give you the line in general form
they'll give it to you in some other
form so your first job before you even
write down the formula is get it in
general form and then you have an a B
and C and you can be put it okay but
being that this is a nice introductory
question it's about as simple as you can
get you can see your a B and C there
don't forget that C is negative it
catches the time with it and there's
your X on Loewen so that's some of you
okay I absolutely fell you 12
5 1-3
right so you can see what's going on all
I need to do is evaluate this it's not
hard to evaluate because you care minus
24 plus 5 minus 3 what's that square
another one you ought to recognize it
it's gonna be 13 because 5 2 or 13 is a
very popular you triad what's happening
on the top minus 24 plus 5 minus 3
that's going to be minus 22 on 13 see
you again that